quand on vous associe à une révolution
c'est quand même lourd quand même et
voilà j'espère être à la hauteur de ce
que mon peuple attend de moi
[Musique]
non
cela
c'est la petite fille d'un martyr de la
révolution et j'ai vécu avec ça je ne
pouvais pas être quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
j'ai écrit cette chanson parce que j'ai
senti le besoin d'appeler à une
manifestation à une
révolution pour pouvoir enfin de compte
changer les choses s'étaient pas
vraiment la bienvenue
une chanson au début et ça va ça m'a
porté préjudice auprès d'eux des
institutions de la culture en algérie et
tout ça et c'est grâce à ça que j'ai été
blacklisté par tous
sur toutes les télés
radio
[Musique]
et maintenant
c'était le seul choix qu'on avait
marie a vécu en république tchèque et
voilà c'était la seule direction à
prendre enfin sa mort
trois fois plus forte et je
ça me donne encore plus de d'énergie
pour continuer ce que j'ai toujours
commencer même quand j'étais en algérie
mais je garde espoir
je garde espoir
[Musique]
je
non
[Musique]
j'appelle les systèmes et je demande
tout simplement qu'ils quittent il n'est
plus le bienvenu
il est aujourd'hui rejeté par tout le
peuple un peuple qui sort depuis elle a
plusieurs fois par semaine pour demander
au pire pour revendiquer justement les
départs de ce système qui elle a deux
pieds 62 voilà donc c'était juste un
ras-le-bol et il n'y a pas trente six
mille façons de faire
[Musique]
le condamné
tout les sépare
[Musique]
je vais poster la vidéo peut-être à
minuit je crois et ensuite j'ai dormi le
matin je trouve des textos sur mon
téléphone qu'ils disent
waouh ta chanson elle a fait ceci elle a
fait cela à moi j'étais vraiment pas
encore réveillé et je jeu rennes je
réalise est vraiment pas ce qui se passe
je m'attendais pas à un tel succès pour
être honnête avec vous du moment que je
les fais juste pour participer à ce qui
se passait à ce
cette belle révolution pacifique mais
mes énormes quand même c'était vraiment
pas calculé parce que pour moi c'était
la suite logique
si moi je
je n'y participe pas je vois pas qui
d'autre pouvait le faire
[Musique]
je n'ai rien demandé du tout et ceux qui
me connaissent savent très bien que je
suis pas trop pour ce genre de titres
puisqu'à la base je fais pas ce que je
fais pour les titres voilà après c'est
vrai que maintenant quand on content
quand on cite raja meusienne et on y
associe avec la révolution a géré ça me
ça me rend fier
[Musique]